excuse me for the bathroom
hi excuse me yeah yeah I need you to
take your seat the fast and seat belt
sign is on yeah I'm just gonna go to the
bathroom for a second I'll be right back
okay I understand what you want to do
unfortunately I'm gonna need you to
observe the fast and seat belt cyan
that'd be much appreciated
right just I read on the internet that
it's not against the law for me to go to
the bathroom while the fast and seat
belt sign is on so
but is it against the law though
the light is on
is it against the law
you see that there's a picture of a seat
belt on that side no but is it against
the law though
the pheases but is it against Sirens
but is it against the lights on
inside
it's very long difficult you're being
very difficult
not illegal not illegal not a legal okay
legal illegal